happy 2017 that's right 2017 is here it
is a month and last year I did a video
called my 10 most anticipated movies of
2016 you guys liked it so now in the
beginning of 2017 I figure I might as
well do a video talking about my 10
anticipated movies in 2017 and this is
an account Desna is in no particular
order in fact the order it's in is order
of release so don't take the first one
there's the one I'm looking forward to
the lease and the last one the one I'm
looking forward to the most so it's not
gonna be a countdown like number 10
number 9 number am just gonna rattle
them off here give you some thoughts on
them while I do it
and hustle keep in mind I'm not looking
forward to just 10 they're actually
quite a few movies I'm looking forward
to but as it is a list of 10 I had to
keep it to 10 so now let's talk about
the 10 well first off early in the year
we have it is coming to us John wick -
yeah who's not looking for does that
John wick one was awesome John wick was
[ __ ] awesome
Keanu Reeves is [ __ ] awesome so I'm
hoping John wick 2 is in and of itself
yeah [ __ ] awesome this because John
wick was such a surprise you know you go
into this movie like yeah I guess and
then you watch it good oh my god that
was absurdly entertaining it was
action-packed it was exciting I had a
cool comic book ish world it built
within this movie I'm hoping it keeps up
for the second one you know there's that
fear because you know I've been there
for the taken movies or you like first
ones great so I'm hoping John wick 2 is
actually a great companion piece a great
sequel to the first John wick but coming
up next is Logan I mean I like the x-men
movies as they are some I like some I
love some I loathe Logan looks like a
horse of a different color someone
watched the Last of Us was like yeah you
know video game movies suck unanimously
so I'm going to you know make the Last
of Us with Wolverine it'd be an Hugh
Jackman's final Wolverine movie it looks
like it could be a great proper send-off
for his character and him from the
franchise you know this personal story
with him it's gonna it looks like he's
gonna have heart it's gonna have action
for sure but it looks like it's not
going to rely on that to tell the story
it looks like it's going to be something
deeper makes me look forward to it you
imagine that Best Actor nomination Hugh
Jackman Logan awesome next in the same
month of Logan Kong Skull Island right
in the world where everything has to
have crossovers and cinematic universes
that's just the world we live in
I accept my reality and I embrace the
fun that this could bring we have
Godzilla now we have Kong the two are
going to fight eventually let's see
where Kong's coming from before these
Titans clash I mean the trailer
was great I like the angle they're taken
with Congress like he's not a bad king
you guys were just dicks when he came to
his home he started dropping bombs of
course he's gonna wreck your helicopter
some people are afraid of it being too
comedic with john c reilly I could see
where you're coming from I have faith
that John C Reilly's character being the
comedic one can organically be woven
into this world and is moving and going
on faith and ability of those involved
for sure
maybe I'm just going on hope I don't
know all I know is this does look rad
next one is alien covenant alright
Prometheus is a mixed bag for most
people are there people who like for me
these people who don't like Prometheus
for me I enjoyed Prometheus I just see
it as its own movie not part of the
Alien franchise and if you do that I
feel like you can enjoy it as its own
sci-fi a lot more I'm just with Wiggly
Scott's touch alone the movie looks
glorious it looked gorgeous lot less
green-screen a lot more props there was
something about that organic feel to it
that I really dug this is the movie that
is weaving the two worlds together it's
like yeah that was an alien prequel
leading into the alien movies let me
show you how the trailer alone you like
it that looks more like an alien movie
than a Prometheus movie yes the two
worlds are connecting hard next up we
have Wonder Woman yes there are a lot of
people out there who have lost faith in
the DC movies elad DC Cinematic Universe
is done for me not quite done for me
Wonder Woman is the one it's detached
from all that [ __ ] it's in the past it
has the freedom to form its own story
before all this Justice League before
the batman vs superman stuff started
happening she is a warrior fighting in
world war 1 and it being Wonder Woman
and a war is happening I have to then
assume that the God of War Ares is in
this film too Early's has a part in it
and that intrigues I get excited on that
[ __ ] after I read Brian Azzarello Wonder
Woman arc I just I fell in love with the
Wonder Woman character I want to see
what they do you guys know Spiderman was
my voice high school now we have
Spiderman phone coming I'm gonna not
look forward to spider-man homecoming I
feel like I'm being redundant putting it
out here because when the trailers are
talking about how I'm looking forward to
it pretty sure in the Civil War review
or at least the Civil War spoiler video
I did when Civil War came out I talked
about on Jack for this movie and the
trailer came out I was like yep
I am excited for this the spider-man
trailer they came out with where it
concentrates on the high school element
of Peter Parker really reminded me why I
love Peter Parker and spider-man when I
was in high school because superheroes
were like eat your green vegetables on
YouTube can be
her hero Peter Parker was like nah I'm
one of the nerds who reads comic books
and I'm a superhero he should be called
spider boy but he's not a Spider Man
next up we have war for the Planet of
the Apes all right when the first movies
great
second movies great third one's coming
out I have to say yeah I'm hoping that
one's great in fact I have to assume
that that one's going to be great he's
just fighting the good fight he never
wanted a war didn't want this with the
people didn't want this conflict with
the humans but he's been put in this
situation now he's here third movie down
I keep saying oh this one land it's
gonna be a great trilogy I know they're
going to make more for sure there's
something about having a trilogy I
always feel like all right now if if the
other one suck at least I have my solid
trilogy a lot riding on it man I just
love me a solid three movie arc and I'm
hoping this one delivers next one is
Dunkirk that's right Christopher Nolan's
one of my favorite directors working
right now he's coming out with a world
war two epic how can I be like yeah yeah
can't happen man just like Christopher
Nolan's coming out with a movie that's
an experience it's an event for me
interstellar taught me a very important
thing sometimes when you watch a movie
give it time to marinate maybe watch it
a second time then do your review don't
just power out the review because of the
competitive world of YouTube was an
important lesson a lesson I actually
enacted a few times in 2016 I'm glad I
did so Dunkirk eh maybe I'll watch it
twice before reviewing it who knows all
I know is Christopher Nolan's making a
war movie let me sign on the dotted line
let's get on this next up Blade Runner
20 49 or 2049 however the kids are
saying that these days like Blade Runner
is one of those movies I saw in junior
high I was like and but that's because I
watched one version of the four versions
of five versions that exist if that was
you if you stopped Blade Runner when you
were younger like don't care I do urge
you to possibly give it a second chance
watch it with adult eyes the point is I
heard about a Blade Runner sequel for
decades of my life this is the point
where you're like that's just never
going to happen we know that and you
accept the reality of that situation
then one day holy [ __ ] blade runner's
happening Blade Runner 2 now it's Blade
Runner 2049 oh and now there's a trailer
for it just something about that just
made it real for me and the director of
arrivals behind this I'm gonna check it
out I want to check that out and we come
to the last one on the list Star Wars
Episode eight yeah no [ __ ] hi I'm Jeremy
nice to meet ya Star Wars movies coming
out this year levar do it I feel like to
be fair as you do a top 10 list that is
actually a top 11 because the no [ __ ]
scenario of a Star Wars movie is going
to be on
one every year those either like yeah I
do a top nine because who are we kidding
the tenth one is a no-brainer or do a
top ten with no Star Wars knowing that
Star Wars is going to be on there you
just name other [ __ ] I'm just saying the
fact is Star Wars is coming out any
given year is gonna get me excited for
it Star Wars on another level I don't
know I have a year to Mull it over and
figure it out one is for now Star Wars
Episode eight on here I feel like this
is the time to do new [ __ ] the force
awakens we got it it was a great
throwback I'm glad it happened the way
it did
I'm telling I feel like they're gonna go
in new directions with Episode eight I
mean just didn't seeing that so bring on
Star Wars Episode a it's on my list it
doesn't even have a something no one
knows what the title is the first order
strikes back I'll call it that all right
guys so I mean in the end that's my list
those are the 10 movies I'm looking
forward to like I said there's actually
15 20 probably 25 movies I'm looking
forward to because I'm an optimist but
if I'm gonna Whittle it down to 10 these
are the 10 that stand out to me I mean
they're super jacked for them or
interested in them point is I'm thinking
about them and these are the ones I'm
thinking about all right guys so your 10
movies you were looking forward to in
2017 what are they whatever they are
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]